figure one the horse
this is a story about a horse
a horse whose fate was inextricably tied
to the invention of film and it all
started with an innocent question do all
four of a horse's hooves
leave the ground at any point during a
gallop
leland stamford yes the dignified chap
who founded stanford university
thought they did
all four of a horse's hooves leave the
ground while galloping but some other
academics thought they didn't one foot
is most certainly always touching the
ground so to put the matter to rest
stanford hired a professional
photographer edward muybridge to capture
the truth on film
there was a bet
thousands of dollars were at stake as
well as a man's reputation
but wait
cameras at the time could not capture
things moving quickly there was no such
thing as a movie camera in 1878
so muybridge had to get creative
he devised an ingenious solution
12 wire triggers and 12 shutters for 12
cameras all evenly spaced to capture a
horse and carriage on a racetrack
the carriage was driven across the
tripwires setting off all 12 cameras in
less than half a second
capturing
the truth
you can clearly see all four hooves have
left the ground
leland stamford was right but honestly
we don't really care about the horse
what we do care about however is muy
bridge's newfangled contraption used to
photograph things in motion
see what i'm getting at here
thomas edison and the lumiere brothers
certainly did they took muybridge's
invention and changed the course of
media as we know it
creating
the motion picture
as for the academics who lost the bet
they're fine
they had tender
[Music]
ferrari lamborghini
simply the ultimate in vehicular luxury
right
well
in italy lamborghini started out
associated with tractors
so how did lamborghini evolve from
tilling the fields of bologna to
becoming one of the top luxury brands on
the planet
through a personal insult delivered by
this man mr ferrari himself
[Music]
ferruccio lamborghini was a real man
with real skills
as an italian air force mechanic during
world war ii he set up a little auto
repair shop in northern italy buying
surplus military machines and converting
them into tractors
he made a lot of money
so much money that he could finally
afford a ferrari 250 gt
a true sign that he had made it
but
there was a problem
so he took a trip to visit enzo ferrari
himself to complain
ferrari
notorious for writing off his customers
through shade at the tycoon tractor
maker exclaiming
the problem is not with the car
but with the driver go focus on your
tractors
game on lamborghini was furious about
ferrari's fiery affront and decided to
build his own car just despite him
lamborghini poached a few of ferrari's
ex-employees
and told them to get to work on beating
their former boss at his own game
the team succeeded with the result being
the lamborghini 350 gt
and the rest
is history
elvis i just told you
i already said that
[Music]
it's november 6 1814
in the belgian city of dinant in a
modest house built on a street that
would later bear his name adolf sacks
was born
28 years later while living in paris
sacks would invent the saxophone and
revolutionize music in ways he couldn't
imagine
but this isn't that story this is the
story of how adolf sacks escaped death
seven times before inventing the
saxophone
hardly old enough to stand the young
adolf fell down three flights of stairs
a stone floor broke his fall
the age of three adolf swallowed a bowl
of water down sulfuric acid mistaking it
for milk
years later adolf found himself a bit
too close to a gunpowder explosion
he was again burned when a cast iron
frying pan was knocked over onto
later a roof stone fell on his head
leaving a lifelong scar
adolf once nearly asphyxiated and when
recently varnished items were left in
his bedroom overnight he woke up barely
playing with friends in a nearby river
adolf was swept up in a swift's current
and nearly drowned again
he survived
on february 7 1894 adolf died peacefully
in paris
the saxophone had already crossed the
atlantic primed to evolve into an icon
of american jazz music and guaranteeing
sex his immortality
[Music]
listen
this sound is the first evidence of the
big bang
and this is a story of two radio
astronomers who discovered proof of the
beginning of everything
[Music]
this is the horn reflector antenna at
bell laboratories robert can you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction it's
pointed to
and funnels them into a receiver that's
robert wilson radio astronomer in the
early 60s he and his colleague arno
penzias were tasked with measuring the
brightness of the sky using the horn
reflector antenna but no matter where
they pointed it the antenna read a much
larger signal than the pair expected our
immediate reaction was that there must
be something wrong with our system they
thought it might be interference from
the horn itself or new york city or even
some pigeons living in the horn you know
we thought about a collection of
ordinary sources that are in the very
distance that just didn't seem to be
possible so they reached out to a group
of researchers at princeton university
led by astrophysicist robert dickey who
had been scouring the sky unsuccessfully
for evidence of the big bang arnold
called and
dickie picked up the phone
and they started hearing things like
atmospheric radiation sky brightness
all the things that they were working on
dickie put the phone down and said boys
we've been scooped
robert and arno had measured what dickey
and his team were searching for the
elusive cosmetic microwave background
radiation
he thought about a big bang source of
the universe realized that it would be
very hot and therefore full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cool
and whereas it was
extremely hot to start with by now it
would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves
and this nut pigeons or the noisy city
was exactly what had been causing
headaches for robert wilson and arno
penzias the two groups of researchers
from bell labs and princeton each wrote
complementary research papers with their
findings they wrote one about the theory
we wrote one about our measurement and
we published them i think unlike many
changes that occur in science there
really was a paradigm shift with very
little pushback
it was huge there was now evidence of a
new theory for the beginning of the
entire universe over a decade later
robert wilson and arno penzias were
awarded the 1978 nobel prize in physics
how'd that feel robert
felt pretty strange to win the nobel
prize i didn't feel comfortable being on
the same list with einstein but despite
robert's humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times
is one of the centerpieces of cosmology
[Music]
you know this guy william shakespeare
he's widely regarded as the greatest
writer in the english language and
here's steve with his harris hawk margot
hi steve
what do they both have in common
let me explain
so what is falconry
falconry is defined as the art of using
a trained bird of prey flying at quarry
it's essentially it's catching your
dinner using a bird of prey it's been
around for thousands of years and it was
so popular back in the 16th century that
shakespeare started using in his
literature
he was such a prolific falconer that
everyone started using his phrases so
much so these expressions are ingrained
in the english language today
like fed up
when margo has been out hunting what
happens is she will eat until she gets
to a point where literally she's fed up
to here she's full she doesn't want to
do anything so she sits still looks
miserable and therefore we say to people
like the kids look at you sitting there
looking fed up
[Music]
birds for thousands of years have always
worn these two little gestures these
leather straps attached to each leg and
when we hold on to her we put them under
the thumb and through the fingers
therefore we have restraint therefore we
can hold him back just like an errant
husband all you've got to bear in mind
is if something's been around for so
long then it's bound to have an impact
on the vernacular
[Music]
the falcon generally wears a hood
because it's very highly strong very
nervous and the hood is a calming down
device and what we do is when we put the
hood on him we're actually fooling him
into thinking it's gone dark so you've
tricked him i hoodwinked him using a
hood to think it's night time so he
relaxes
well as holding these leather straps
adjusters the leash fastens onto the
glove and then we wrap it around the
fingers like a belt and braces it's an
extra precaution in case you lose the
bird
[Music]
haggard comes from um an old bird that
is learnt to hunt you trapper once she's
learned to hunt therefore she's a better
hunter because she's learnt on her own
which is where we get the word an old
hag from now and how many people have
used that every day and don't realize
it's actually a falconry expression
so there we have it thanks shakespeare
you